we'll often talk on the show
about how on so many different issues
the country meaning the voters
are as we'll often talk on the show
about how on so many different issues
the country meaning the voters
are as far left as they have been
often times for as long as we've been
keeping track of certain metrics so as
an example we'll often say well when you
ask people should abortion be legal in
most cases uh we have more approval for
that yes abortion should be legal in
most cases today than at any point
during the
roe v wade era which started decades and
decades ago we talk about gay marriage
for example we'll talk about well should
the government provide some basic level
of health care to everybody regardless
of ability to pay
but another area in which public opinion
has shifted towards the left over the
last many years that does not get as
much attention is support for labor
unions labor unions in the united states
are experiencing based on this brand new
gallup poll
that came out
under two weeks ago which i did not talk
about but i'm talking about today
approval for labor unions in the united
states is at its highest point since
1965 that's 57 years
and when you look at the numbers you now
see that 68 of americans currently
approve of labor unions that's a number
that bottomed out at 48 percent in 2009
that got close to 68
in the late 90s and early 2000s but you
have actually have to go all the way
back to 1965 where you see that support
for labor unions was at 71 now this is
data that we have going back a long way
because gallup has measured this support
for labor unions going all the way back
to 1936 and there was a period in the
united states from 36 to 67 roughly
where if you're looking at this uh chart
uh you see this graph
you see that there was just generally
higher support in that roughly 30-year
period you had an average of 68 support
for labor unions in the united states
that dropped into the mid to high 50s
for a while and went even lower around
the time of the great recession but
those numbers have now recovered and the
interesting question would be why
one part of this is when you break down
these numbers by party affiliation
democrats republicans independents it
won't shock you that support among
democrats is where labor union support
is highest but even among democrats
labor union support has also hit a
20-year high labor union support among
democrats has always been higher in this
entire period but it is particularly
higher right now as well and to
understand what's going on you need only
look at sort of the world around us in
the united states
people are increasingly understanding
that we need some counter balancing
power or influence
against the power of corporations and
against the power of employers in the
employee employer relationship
this is a reaction to what is correctly
being seen out in the world
uh the gig economy
more and more people realizing how
absurd the disconnect between
productivity and wages has become even
if you don't know that technically even
if you don't have the data in front of
you
intuitively there is a sense of that
and it is true that on some of these
things the pendulum sort of switch uh
swings back and forth and there are
periods where the country moves away
from favoring labor unions to some
degree and moves back in favor of labor
unions the key
is what can you get done when the
pendulum is swinging in your favor what
can you accomplish when support is
higher
i think it also should be mentioned
that president joe biden
is arguably more pro-union vocally so
than any recent president i mean
certainly in the last 20 or so years uh
and he talks about it as well and joe
biden's background uh riding the amtrak
train amtrak also has been in the news
for what appears to be a narrowly
averted major work stoppage uh labor
strike uh biden talks about that
certainly more than trump
more than obama of course more than bush
and i guess you have to go back and
think well is it sort of like a clinton
level amount of talking about labor
unions so none of this should shock us
the optimistic thing
is
we often worry and i talk about this on
the show all the time
that there's a disconnect
between
what is happening in the country
and public opinion so for example you
will see the republican party
swing
cartoonishly and absurdly into this maga
world where there is no more policy
it's
authoritarianism
and sort of fascistic dictatorial wet
dreaming in terms of what they would
like to see while claiming to be about
small government what it just doesn't
make any sense and we sometimes see that
the republican party electorate or just
voters in general they don't see the
scope of what is happening within the
republican party and this ends up with
you know herschel walker might defeat
raphael warnock in georgia and it's
horrible in other words we often are
concerned that the people are not
reacting to the reality of what's going
on
the good news here
if we want to find some good news beyond
just oh it's good that people are so are
more in favor of labor unions
is that
this is an accurate and logical reaction
to what is happening uh in terms of the
relationships between employer and
employee in terms of the
disproportionate power that large
corporations have not only with regard
to their employees but also with regard
to taxation and so many other things so
this is good to see the question now
becomes what's going to be done about it
will there actually be any steps in
terms of the democratization of work joe
biden has ideas that are going nowhere
naturally because of uh what's going on
in the senate right now and not having
60 votes but we're going to continue
talking about it and the first step in
achieving change is public opinion
uniting and we're seeing that to some
degree
florida governor ron desantis has pulled
a disgusting political stunt that
actually isn't that terrible for some of
the people involved and i'll explain
that in a moment but the big headline is
that ron desantis flew 50 migrants to
the swanky island of martha's vineyard
and this is really just a sick political
stunt it's meant to trigger and own the
libs and on and on and on but i'm going
to argue that this is actually quite the
opposite a business insider has a report
about this desantis sent 50 migrants to
martha's vineyard by plane as an
anti-liberal stunt the locals pulled
together to help them now i i've spent a
lot of time on martha's vineyard and as
soon as i saw the headlines my instinct
was
i don't know that this is going to work
out necessarily the way ron desantis
imagines it working out because martha's
vineyard is very very liberal
extraordinarily liberal and it only
follows logically that you are going to
see
the people of martha's vineyard come
together to help these 50 individuals
as the story goes governor this is
business insider governor ron desantis
of florida sent plane loads of migrants
to martha's vineyard in massachusetts it
was apparently intended to shift some of
the burden of migration to a rich
liberal area
locals at the exclusive destination
where barack obama
owns property rallied to help out
state senator julian cyr of
massachusetts told the new york times
about 50 migrants arrived in two planes
with no warning
fox news digital reported the story and
had video of migrants disembarking from
planes all right you can imagine what it
looks like for people to get off of a
plane
yes florida can confirm the two planes
with illegal immigrants that arrived in
martha's vineyard today were part of the
state's relocation program to transport
illegal immigrants to sanctuary
destinations that's taran fenske the
comms director for desantis
and then you just have to look at the
reaction from the island of martha's
vineyard dylan fernandez posting our
island jumped into action putting
together 50 beds giving everyone a good
meal providing a play area for the
children making sure people have the
health care and support they need we are
a community that comes together to
support immigrants
another article from cbs florida's
desantis flies dozens of illegal
immigrants to martha's vineyard
escalating tactic against quote
sanctuary destinations think about how
absurd this is first of all
florida spends a bunch of money to fly
people out
these folks appear to actually have come
from texas not even from florida so it's
like why is ron desantis even involved
why is taxpayer money being spent to
move people from texas to massachusetts
that doesn't even make sense first and
foremost secondly from a fiscal
conservatism point of view
i think it would have been cheaper for
florida
to set up temporary housing and
vocational training for these folks
eventually making them a productive tax
paying component of the florida economy
rather than just blowing a few million
dollars of taxpayer money to fly people
from texas to massachusetts for a
political stunt and by the way if these
folks eventually want to go back to
texas they're going to be able to do it
and nothing's going to stop them and ron
desantis isn't going to track them down
and fly them out again so it's not only
absurd
sort of superficially
but it doesn't even make sense in terms
of a political stunt with taxpayer money
now in the meantime
the the migrants are now in martha's
vineyard rather than florida or texas
and statistically without casting any
aspersions or judgment without making
any moral statement if you look at the
hdi that's the human development index
of massachusetts florida and texas which
is a metric that considers a number of
different types of well-being the
migrants are certainly far better off in
massachusetts than they would be in
florida or texas but that's sort of a
different story and then the last kind
of a
absurd or ironic component of this is
that when ron desantis pulls these
stunts and sends people from red states
to blue states or when abbot greg abbott
the governor of texas republican has
also pulled these types of stunts before
aren't you incentivizing immigration
because you're sending the signal to
migrants
undocumented immigration that would be
you're sending the signal to migrants
hey listen
even if where you would manage to get
is texas which i mean you know just look
at the data texas is no it's no beauty
when it comes to access to health care
education quality all these different
things
you get yourself to taxes we'll get you
to a much better state by most metrics
by pulling this stun
you're arguably incentivizing the very
undocumented immigration that you want
to disincentivize by saying we'll
upgrade you
to a state with higher income
more access to health care
better infrastructure and better
education they claim to want to
disincentivize that very undocumented
immigration it's a pathetic stunt
i don't know what this does to public
opinion it's an empirical question we
have to wait and see
but by every metric we can measure a
very stupid stunt let me know your
thoughts maybe i'm missing something
find me on twitter at deepakman also
remember that monday 9 19 just four days
away
we are doing our blowout
historic
membership special you've been thinking
of becoming a member this is a perfect
time to do it get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
and then monday morning you will get a
perfect email telling you exactly how to
avail yourself of this great membership
discount listen to this headline a
trumpist
with guns
wearing a clown wig was arrested at
dairy queen for threatening to kill
democrats that headline
i don't know that it would have
necessarily been a believable headline
10 years ago or 15 years ago in the
united states but it is now a very real
headline you have to see the story
there's a very uh good cbs news article
about it police
armed man wearing clown wig said he
wanted to kill all democrats this is um
unbelievable
uh the story goes uh delmont
pennsylvania
a westmoreland county man is facing
several charges after police said he
wanted to quote kill all democrats this
is jan or maybe it's pronounced jan
stowovey 61 years old took a loaded gun
into a delmont dairy queen and police
said the quick action of an officer
saved lives this was five days ago
saturday september 10th when delmont
police say stawevi walked into a dairy
queen on state route 66 in a yellow
safety vest and rainbow clown wig
callers told police he had a gun within
a minute officer gregory stahl was there
multiple people were inside the dairy
queen at the time and police say a group
of people including several with
intellectual disabilities were heading
inside officer stealth found stewovi and
took him into custody well great that's
all good but look at some of these
details police found a loaded 40 caliber
handgun and ammo on him
stawvey allegedly told police he was
quote undercover
and he was quote working to restore
trump
to president king
of the united states
he said he was armed to quote
kill democrats and liberals
and to protect himself from quote
drug traffickers
when they started to look at stawi's
facebook page they found a history of
outbursts and threats
in the last two years stawevi had been
asked to leave two different
congregations leading up to the arrest
both congregations sent him letters
saying the you had outbursts and you
were threatening
um
you can sort of imagine
this person's political views he had
photos on social media showing support
for trump and a post saying civil war in
2024
as of the writing of this article
stavovi was not yet in jail but was in
custody awaiting a preliminary
arrangement arraignment
so there's really two different stories
here and every time we read about a
story like this
you see this mishmash of reactions
thrown at the wall like okay
the fact that this guy was a trumpist
this is the the defenders will say the
fact that this guy was a trumpist is
irrelevant and a mere coincidence this
is a mentally ill person
this is a mentally ill person
fundamentally and it really has nothing
to do with trumpism there are three
different important reactions to that
first of all it is true
that there are mentally ill people who
will eventually become fixated on
something
trumpism is one outlet but were it not
for trumpism at least some of these
folks i agree with you would become
fixated on you know is it a 9 11
conspiracy
is it a child pedophilia conspiracy at a
pizza place in dc right we've seen it so
some of these folks the trump is the
trumpet fascination
is uh incidental and it could be about
something else but
it is also true
that trumpism is attracting more of
these folks
than just kind of like
middle of the road democratic party
politics trumpism is attracting more of
these folks
than social progressivism so we can't
write that off yes mental illness sure
but there's something about trumpism
here that is attracting these folks
secondly
if you really believe that what's at
issue here is mental illness
why isn't more being done by the very
right wing that claims this is all about
merely mental illness it's not about
trumpism and it's certainly not about
guns
why aren't they doing more to prevent
mentally ill folks like this guy
from being able to have guns because the
guy had guns and ammo
which as of right now
is believed were purchased legally so
the very people who want to do nothing
about the guns and say this is about
mental illness
they aren't doing anything to get guns
out of the hands of mentally ill people
and we know that there were two churches
here who had sent him off and said you
can't be here you're threatening etc
there should be some mechanism
and it should be a requirement for the
church if they had a knowledge that this
guy owned firearms to report to someone
here's someone who's unstable we've
kicked them out for these reasons we
believe they have guns it should be
looked at
uh also last thing the the number of
stories related to like fast food and
convenience stores recently
mike pillow was uh raided by the fbi at
a hardy's drive-through
this guy's at a dairy queen
i hope that if trump ever does get
arrested he'll be found at kfc elbow
deep in a bucket of chicken that would
really be the final poetic chapter to
this entire thing
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com pacman you
will get aura free for 14 days which you
can use to do things like see if your
passwords have been leaked the link is
down below
we have a news of yet another one of
these tragic accidents the daily beast
is reporting that another vladimir putin
ally
has been found dead after quote
suffocating on a business trip
from a quote
stroke
hmm
another top ally reports the daily beast
of russian president vladimir putin
has died this week this time of an
alleged stroke while on a business trip
in the village of rosschino in russia's
far east region
vladimir sungorkin 68 years old was
editor-in-chief of the russian state
newspaper
according to the newspaper sin gorkhan
died suddenly after showing signs of
suffocation during the trip the all of
these terms are in quotes even in the
article by the way
quote it happened absolutely suddenly
nothing foreshadowed we were in the
village of rostino we were driving we
were already making our way towards
kabarovsk we planned to get there in the
evening and from there to moscow all was
good said his colleague who accompanied
him on the business trip
according to zakharov sengorkin fell
unconscious minutes after suggesting
their group find a beautiful place for
lunch three minutes later vladimir began
to suffocate we took him out for fresh
air he was unconscious nothing helped
the doctor who did the initial exam said
apparently it was a stroke but this is
only the initial conclusion
uh now some of you may be confused wait
why why did a putin ally die i thought
it was putin antagonists and putin
enemies who kept accidentally dying
remember two weeks ago i told you about
the guy who these are just tragic
accidents he was in the hospital for
treatment for a serious illness
and he just fell out the window at the
hospital very very tragic accident now
that was an antagonist of putin so
here's what you have to understand
there's a bit of both going on
the the way that this is believed to
function is
the putin antagonists are sometimes
killed
but also putin allies
that are suspected of jumping ship
or are suspected of moving in a disloyal
way
they also sometimes have to be taken out
and wikipedia actually maintains an
article
called 2022
russian businessman mystery deaths
and you can just look through this and
see the list and it is wild wild wild
wild and the list is quite long
um you might remember reveal maganov
he's the guy i told you about who was
reportedly hospitalized for heart
problems and depression
and then quote fell out of a window
and was a big um
putin critic
so
as we've talked about before
many of you when we do these stories
will react and say david this stuff is
so obvious like no one believes that
these are accidents or deaths from
illness
why isn't putin slicker in how he does
it that's exactly the point as i've told
you before the whole point here is
it's important that it be known that
these stupid explanations are just
untrue stupid explanations that's the
idea that's how you sow fear if it was
really believed that this was a stroke
and the other guy fell out the window or
whatever
then it wouldn't have the chilling
effect that it's meant to have and so
we're going to continue tracking these
it's about uh i believe uh 20 or 22
various oligarchs allies and antagonists
who have died in just tragic accidents
supposedly is what we're supposed to
believe um we're going to continue
following that list and you can check
out that list on the wiki page which we
will link to
there's a little bit of a rehabilitation
of melania trump that's happening and
the latest attempt at this is
um the claim from a forthcoming book
that melania slammed trump for his
dealing with covet early in the pandemic
when trump was still president you're
blowing this is the quote that is in
this new book there's a cnn article
about this by kevin liptak which you can
read in a couple of minutes uh trump's
top general
feared he would authorize a strike on
iran as his presidency ended his
intelligence chief wondered what russia
had on him a billionaire friend
convinced him to try buying greenland a
half dozen top officials considered
resigning in mass even his wife first
lady melania was quote rattled by the
coronavirus and convinced that trump was
screwing up
according to a forthcoming book from the
new york times chief white house
correspondent peter baker and new yorker
staff writer susan glasser set to
publish next tuesday
in a phone call with former new jersey
governor chris christie
melania trump sought help convincing her
husband to take the pandemic more
seriously you're blowing this she
recalled telling her husband the
author's right this is serious it's
going to be really bad and you need to
take it more seriously than you're
taking it he had just dismissed her you
worry too much she remembered him saying
forget it
so
this really does very little positive
for melania trump's image and what i
mean by that is
everyone at the time knew that trump was
blowing it everybody knew that trump was
blowing it was it was absurd trump's
handling of the coronavirus pandemic was
pathetic remember saying 15 cases will
soon be zero
would a flu shot prevent covid
all of it okay he completely blew it and
everybody knew it and it was clear at
the time
melania trump didn't come out and
publicly say a word about this
this doesn't absolve her of anything now
i understand it is it reasonable to
expect the first lady to come out and
publicly say my husband is blowing this
no but the point is it's no great
feat that we now find out that she
thought he was blowing it at the time
everybody thought that trump was blowing
it at the time and you can actually
argue it's worse she knew how bad it was
and nothing was done
um trump's handling of kovid and i think
this is the most important takeaway now
in retrospect was a failure not just
medically obviously it was a failure
medically it was arguably one of trump's
biggest political failures
trump could have easily sailed to
re-election if from the start of the
pandemic he said
we are going to beat this back better
than any other country we're going to
wear
mega masks he could have monetized the
maga medical masks
we are the ultimate patriots with our
mega masks stopping kobit we're going to
listen to doctors
and we are going to be the best at this
let's do it
and then he would have sailed to
re-election and we know that it would
have worked because it worked in other
countries there are a number of other
world leaders who had re-election
campaigns during the pandemic in the
earlier phase of the pandemic they did
handle it properly the country rallied
around them and they easily won
reelection and trump could have so for
all of the blaming that now is done in
retrospect oh the it was the problem was
they they stole it with uh mail-in
ballots and massive dumps in the middle
of the night and all of this stuff
trump could have easily won re-election
simply by taking the
we are the patriots of all patriots
by dealing with this as seriously as
other countries
and trump would be president right now
so great melania knew what everybody
knew trump was completely blowing
coveted
uh we're not going to give her a cookie
no
more on these stories on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
so continuing our candidate interviews
today we're going to be speaking with
johnny teague who's a republican running
in texas's 7th congressional district
that includes
uh some of the swanky parts of houston
texas if i understand correctly uh great
great having you on i appreciate it
it's an honor to be with you thank you
and your audience for having me so
there's a number of different ways we
could start this interview and this
might be a weird thing but just as a
sort of gut check i've been asking a lot
of the different republican candidates
we talked to this question
and i forgive me for such a silly
question but who is the current
president of the united states
current president united states is a
fellow named joe biden okay all right
that's a start uh is is he a legitimate
president in the sense that his election
his presence presidency represents the
will of the voters
i think and i always answer this i don't
want to be dodgy but i believe there's
always question in every election going
back uh
benjamin harrison's election there's
always whoever loses is never fully
contented with the election but
following the electoral votes and all
those other things president biden is
our president just like president trump
was elected in 2016 or george bush in
2000. so and
if the baseline is that the loser always
has some questions
is there anything different in 2020 than
just the norm of the loser never really
being fully satisfied as you say
i don't i don't think so i think well i
will say there are some differences one
difference was because of covid we had
drive in or drive up voting
which we never had that before so yeah
there there were some differences with
voting this time okay but your but big
picture you're not saying it's a
dramatically different situation in
terms of the loser being dissatisfied
that they really lost
no i mean 1960 was a was a
crazy election great questions about it
every every election that hillary
clinton greatly questioned the 2016. so
yeah i think you're right all right
about as reasonable an answer as we've
heard i guess all considered
so um okay in in terms of your platform
you know one of the things i noticed is
that
a lot of your background
is heavily religiously oriented i mean
you you know you're a pastor you have a
master of divinity and your religious
credentials are certainly very present
when one reads about your background in
terms of the relationship between
religion and civil government
do you you believe that there should be
separation there
i believe that there has been separation
the way our founders intended and the
way the founders intended was that
government never ever interfered with
religion didn't sponsor religion it
didn't
favor one religion over another that was
our founder's intent but as far as me
being a christian running for congress
or a pastor
you know i pay taxes just like an
electrician does just like a rancher
does and i'm a rancher and when our when
our founder said it's to be a government
or really coming back to lincoln the
government of the people for the people
by the people i'm part of the people
and uh as i pay taxes as i'm able to
vote
a pastor ought to be able to run for
office just like electrician or a
publisher or a lawyer
absolutely now when you think about your
views on any particular issue and this
is really a very broad philosophical
question you of course
can't separate your religion from your
opinions and so for many folks
their opinion about something like
abortion personally is informed by their
religion which is part of their moral
code without question that that i think
is the case for everybody
do you believe
that those religious views alone
are enough to determine what should be
law in the united states
well let me come back you use the term
religion let me use a different term
world view
not everybody has a religion there's
some more anti-religion there's some who
just are agnostic yeah you could be
absent to religion yeah so so world view
is what we're talking about not religion
my world view is is shaped by my faith
no doubt
but just like someone else's worldview
is shaped by their lack of faith we all
have backgrounds and experiences but
yeah i mean my my sense my belief of
right and wrong is based on two things
god's word and the constitution no
different from john adams who said our
form of government is only for moral
religious people and it's not adequate
for any other so i kind of hold that
same view that john adams held
um your your twitter account is really
interesting now i guess i should say but
do you do you run your own twitter
account or someone else don't i don't
that twitter thing i i guess i guess uh
president trump was a big twitter fella
i'm not a twitter guy i have a little
lady that puts things out there who
volunteers for the campaign
and so i really tried to rein that in
because it's so quick whoever runs your
twitter account
they almost take on the personality of
the candidate when they're not the
candidate the reason i'm glad you're
telling me that because i don't even
know if you know this but on your
twitter account there's a lot of q anon
stuff now just like as a as do are you
have you ever heard the term q anon
before
i have and i when you say there's a lot
of q anon i know in 2020
uh the lady who did my uh twitter thing
put out a q a
she there was something that q anon put
out that she liked and shared it i guess
that's what you do with twitter
and man i started getting all kinds of
calls are you with q and i do you
support q and on and i'm like no i don't
at that time i didn't know who they were
and so i'm praying that you've only seen
one thing on q a and if you well i've
seen four uh you know so so i mean just
glancing through
i saw a retweet of three women taking
what's called the q anon oath i saw a
retweeted video
uh with a jfk junior conspiracy theory
which is a big q anon thing i saw was
that brother i'm sorry
do you remember the dating on those it
says june although i admit it's not
clear whether it's june of this year or
last year
well i'll tell you what and i'm not
trying to be evasive by any means you
can look at my post on facebook you can
look at my post on my website you'll
never see a dog thing on qa9 but if what
you're saying is correct and when we
finish i will make sure to check that
there that will i'll shut the twitter
account down okay but so you're you seem
to be clear like q you you're you have
nothing uh positive to say about q anon
and you're not associated in any way
with that i'm not associated at all and
i thought we'd take care of this in
2020. uh we have a sweet lady named miss
eileen and miss eileen
i'm a guy just running i have about 300
volunteers that work with me nobody's
paid
and so just like i pastor my church i
trust people to do what i expect them to
do and when they don't i have to take
some pretty strong action there you go
so i will shut that puppy down if i find
any q a and stuff and you can check me
in two hours beautiful if there's
anything there it will be gone or the
twitter account will be closed okay fair
let's um let's dig into something policy
oriented just to give our audience a
sense of where you are taxes okay to
pick something that is uh
often
a hot button issue
right now in terms of the federal income
tax brackets and rates that we have
what's your opinion too high too low
just right not enough brackets too many
brackets
well i think we're probably okay right
now with the tax structure
i i don't like that we're 33 trillion 32
trillion dollars in debt
i know that we've just hired or we've
set the bill for 87 000 new irs agents
what i'm finding is we are spending
way too much in government and when you
spend way too much in government
you have got to try to
pay for that somehow so what we do is
raise taxes
and i believe our government's got to
spend less
and tax less especially when i look at
you know everybody should pay their fair
share and everybody ought to pay their
taxes without cheating yes and
i believe that we you know i drive on
those roads that the taxes pay for i
take advantage of the police department
and their protection that those taxes
pay for so as a christian as a pastor as
a citizen of the united states
i believe we pay
what our taxes are and we don't look for
a way out of it and that's a problem
with people in congress i'm afraid and
that's why i'm for term limits eight
years get the heck out serve the people
and don't be
uh financially
rewarded for the time you served because
then that removes the whole word of
service but we find a lot of people in
congress
the very ones who are raising taxes and
hiring rs agents are the ones who pay so
few taxes and so i honestly think every
tax return ought to be made public if
you're in public office if you're
elected
that way you see people are living under
the very laws they're making everybody
else but a short answer to your question
forgive me for going along
short answer your question
i think it's probably okay the way it's
set up as long as taxes aren't
continually being raised as long as
we're not finding other ways to raise
more money to cover overspending so to
just go back to the irs agents thing i
couldn't tell from when you mentioned
the hiring of additional irs agents
whether you see that as a good thing or
a bad thing because it seems as though
being so short staffed those additional
irs agents
will actually
bring in more money by by finding people
who are cheating than what they cost
from the analysis i've seen so are you
are you in favor or against the
additional
oh you're against it
and i i think when you look at what
we're paying for 87 000 i'm not saying
we're not short staffed you know we we
need to make sure that we're well
staffed but 87 000 agents you look at
the cost for those 87 000 agents and
then you got to do the math and figure
out
will they really pay for themselves and
if they just pay for themselves
that's not a benefit at all no that's
true but i guess i would question like
the the congressional budget office
nonpartisan does scoring of all of these
proposals they found that it actually
would bring in more revenue than than
than it would cost do you have something
to contradict that
well no i don't because again i'm not in
congress so i don't get uh special
insights into how they formulated their
no neither am i but i'm just saying is
there anything we both have access to
all the same things do you have anything
that would point in a different
direction
i don't i mean i'm a mathematician
through training but
i'd have to look at it but i i honestly
believe
that we don't need 87 000 irs agents and
i honestly believe that we can we can be
a lot more frugal in what we do and
again
we should never cheat on our taxes we
should pay our taxes in full
in the same light though
we need to not spend beyond what we have
ours our national debt
has eclipsed our gdp
that's just not right we you know johnny
teague in my world
i don't make a lot of money but i can't
spend more than i make and we have got
to apply that i think government should
spend less so we tax less i think we
should not give out as much money but
but as people to earn
uh their living and so i just really
believe and i'll give you an example we
just spent i think 11 million dollars
here in houston to beautify our bus
stops
now i just think
that it's great to be the fire bus stop
sure but 11 million dollars and let me
give you a quick example
my people are campaigning for me they
put out my cards throughout the
community uh one one guy which i hate i
tell them don't put these cards on a car
that irritates people it hacks them off
don't put on the car but one guy put in
a lady's windshield
well it rained here in houston and that
lady tried to pull it off her windshield
after the rain and the paper struck to
the windshield so she called me and she
said johnny
i'm going to vote for you
you have said in your statements you
think we ought to love care for others
and do right i'm gonna see if you're
gonna back that up my windshield i can't
get the paper off my windshield i want
you to come to my house this afternoon
to wash my car
i said ma'am i'm so sorry about that
happening if i was free i'd come wash it
but i'll tell you what uh please go get
it washed and i'll pay for the watch i
promise
so she
called me yesterday
and uh johnny i got my car washed it
looks wonderful i go great she goes now
i got to tell you i'm not able really to
drive it was actually in her in her
front yard she goes so i had to order
one of those mobile car wash companies
to come to my house and wash my car
and i said well i know those are kind of
expensive how much did it cost she said
it was 210 dollars yeah so johnny had to
pay 210 dollars to get a little paper
off the windshield and i asked you the
question
why do you think she was willing to pay
210 dollars well because it was johnny
teague's money no i understand but some
of these analogies i mean you know you
analogized to you can't spend more than
you have so so cun but countries
regularly deficit spend i don't think
deficit spending is necessarily the
issue i mean give me a sense of what
would you cut what do you cut from the
federal budget
well honestly i'd cut
i'd cut some of the departments
i would cut uh
some of the excessive things that we do
which one
which ones
which what which departments and which
excessive things that we do which
departments i honestly would probably
cut the department of education not
surprisingly i would cut the
environmental protection agency i would
probably cut the federal reserve
again i'm coming to you again as an
outsider yeah so please know i don't
have full knowledge of of anything yeah
based you know just like um
you may not have full knowledge on how i
raise my black angus cattle you probably
don't know what i have to do to have my
coastal grow my hay fields
i don't think a lot of the congressmen
would know that because i do that every
day yeah well i'm going to come at you
not be in the know-it-all that's what
i'm actually here to learn from you
brother dave well i would propose johnny
that on department of education
eliminating department of education has
become a popular right-wing
idea
to damage public schools under the
premise that they are liberal
indoctrination to instead support
religious and so-called patriotic
education i don't like it i think i
think it's a trojan horse and the truth
is that if you eliminate the department
of the epa
this idea that every business is
incentivized to police itself when it
comes to pollution it's been proven
false and without the epa
pollution and as a result all sorts of
disease and cancer as a result of that
pollution would explode those are the
perspectives i would encourage you to
consider
well and i actually disagree with you
and i encourage you not surprised
i mean i mean we can go with what you
say or if you want me to share i'll be
happy to
no i mean it's uh i'm just suggesting
you consider those perspectives yeah
yeah absolutely and may i
say i don't believe that uh
wanting to change our department of
education or remove it isn't some right
wing
uh
christian or
biblical pounding thing
you look at how kids are doing right now
in math
for instance and i taught college
algebra
they're doing terrible math that
look at how they're achieving on these
different metrics whether it be science
or english
tech they can't even write cursive
anymore where we have seen that writing
cursive forms the connection the brain
and the memory better than just printing
so i mean these are just basic things i
think we're we're teaching kids the
fringe things
which which i think are fine
but i think we're going to get back to
the basics and so i believe we need to
spend more time teaching math science
english things that are really going to
help kids uh function in life and get a
job afterward after they get out of
school and with the epa
i believe firmly
you're right i think that there have
been great errors in the past great uh
crimes against humanity at times that
have really harmed people we see it even
here in houston where companies
sometimes
more worried about the bottom line than
anything but today in a social conscious
in a social media in a moment by moment
news cycle
i believe there's greater policing i
mean there's a reason oil and gas
companies are looking at wind and solar
and they're looking at clean the
environment uh you see blackrock and
these other investors that are
that are really pressing them
and i'm not a blackrock fan but they're
pressing these companies to be more
socially responsible
so you look at oil and gas right now
people are complaining about the price
of gas and i'm one of them
you look at what our government is
saying again you're going to disagree
but i believe that our government has uh
cut drilling i believe our government
has
cut pipelines i believe our government
has made it hard to have a refinery
and and even i talked to an old
executive the other day and i was an
accountant for shale so i i do have some
oil and gas experience you may say it's
jaded
but an oil and gas guys say johnny
it's more risky
or it's as risky let me be accurate it's
as risky for us to drill in the united
states as it is venezuela and nigeria
and that's because they spend all this
money in r d
they get a well ready to come
and then the government yanks that
license or that permit
and sometimes under the guys are
protecting some species
and yet you look at
wind and solar and the damage it does to
species as well i think we've got to
care for our environment but anyway i
think that regulations are raising
prices uh i think they're harming us i'm
a farmer a race uh hey
fertilizer is three times more this year
than it was last year uh and i know part
of that's the russia invasion of the
ukraine but we're also being told what
fertilizer we can use what we shouldn't
use uh then we're telling food uh
shortages are gonna occur
so i just think that we've got
government does a good job but sometimes
you overreach just like i do well if i
may johnny that was the equivalent of an
ink blot of different things going
between fertilizer prices wind power
species and i don't think it will shock
you that
i disagree with basically everything you
just said but that's uh
gonna have to be for a different
conversation since we have uh uh we our
time today has elapsed um it's an
interesting race that you're running in
the seventh congressional district we've
been speaking with republican johnny
teague
let's see how things go in november and
then we'll uh we'll reconvene from there
and let me say one thing yeah i'm
thankful for you and i'm thankful that
we disagree thank you and i do want to
listen and david i'm not always right in
fact i'm often wrong true but i do want
to learn and and thank you for being so
gracious to me
regardless of where you stand on the
issues i'm thankful we live in a country
where we can be free
and and we can still be brothers and
americans
and and have vast differences on the
issues i appreciate your time thank you
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show so
yesterday we learned about this
incredible situation in which my pillow
founder mike lindell also known as mike
pillow or just pillow we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines that guy yeah he had his phone
seized by the fbi while at a hardy's
drive-through
we now have the search warrant that was
presented to pillow
and the search warrant exposes that this
guy is potentially in extremely serious
trouble
newsweek has it in an article called
read fbi's mike lindell search warrant
items to be seized and if you scroll
down the article
you get to a section
which is the list of everything to be
seized check this out so of course it
says the physical cellular telephone
assigned to pillow which they got
all records and information on the
lindell cell phone that constitute
fruits evidence or instrumentalities of
violations of
identity theft
intentional damage to a protected
computer
conspiracy to cuff link identity theft
and on and on and on and it lists a
number of different people but that is
where it really gets very interesting
when you look at the specifics
so it's a seizure of records and
information relating to damage to
dominion voting systems
there may be crimes here in having
damaged voting machines the guy saying
he's investigating the voting machines
may have damaged voting machines records
and information relating to bios on a
dominion voting system machine records
and information relating to the
attachment of any peripheral to a
dominion voting system machine
records and information relating to any
optical disk drive so a lot of dominion
voting machine stuff okay you then go
further
and you start to see all records and
information relating to conan james
hayes conan james hayes use
of another person's name
photograph credentials or identifying
information or documents who is conan
james hayes
this is uh one of these guys
who um
has spearheaded election disinformation
was involved in the arizona so-called
audit and seems to be wrapped up in the
pillow stuff with the machines
and it all stinks to high heaven and
there's possible identity theft here as
well
another really interesting item is item
m
evidence of who used owned or controlled
the lindell cell phone
at the time things described in the
warrant were created
edited
or deleted so this now it's very clear
that the fbi is also concerned with
destruction of evidence potentially here
evidence of software that would allow
others to control the lindell cell phone
evidence of the attachment to the
lindell cell phone of other storage
devices
and on and on and on this is
extraordinarily detailed and i know many
people will say
anytime the fbi seizes a phone
they have a whole bunch of these
different things there fair
but these are very specific provisions
and items elements for lack of a better
term
that relate to
what mike pillow was up to
and so
there's clearly a concern about deleted
evidence the subpoena includes that and
just think
if trump
and pillow had just stuck with you know
their respective bailiwicks
which for trump was
you know i don't know real estate stuff
and for pillow was selling pillows they
would both probably be
better off right now
certainly legally
and the united states of america would
be dramatically better off we will see
what happens next and by the way this
seizure has completely triggered mike
pillow uh but we'll talk about that more
on tomorrow's program guys in trouble
though guys it seems to be in serious
trouble we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to david p
here is our caller who calls in
regularly juan
who he seems to be taking issue with
double-blind placebo-controlled trials
listen to this
hey david it's juan here
i want to present the case against
double-blind placebo-controlled
and
systematically reviewed trials
so i don't know much about this but uh
okay so that would be the first red flag
i don't know much about this but let's
listen anyway
so if they conduct a trial and
only 10
of the subjects
in the trial
benefit
from
the treatment the whatever
they're going to consider
the trial to not really be
any good i mean
so that's not necessarily true what when
you're
assessing the success the effectiveness
the efficacy of a treatment or drug
you want to
compare
the effectiveness to
the best available treatment and also
have a placebo arm so and it should be
double blind so what you're looking to
do is as follows imagine that you have
some condition let's call it
you know
uh
trump syndrome for lack of a better term
you've got trump syndrome and you have a
pill
that improves symptoms in 10 of people
great
that's the best treatment we have so you
design a test
in which you take some people and you
give them the pill that's already on the
market and you take some people and you
give them a placebo and you take some
people and you give them the new pill
now some would argue you don't even in
this case you don't even really need the
placebo because the whole point is to
compare to the approved treatment but
you could you could do it this way
the people shouldn't know who's getting
what the patient shouldn't know am i
getting the approved pill
a new pill or the placebo because
knowledge of what they're getting could
affect the results
the people treating them shouldn't know
what they're getting either so that that
would not uh influence the results and
then you compare now imagine
if the approved
pill
works 10 of the time
and the placebo works 10 of the time
and the new pill works 40 of the time
that now becomes significant so there's
no hard and fast numbers really the way
juan is saying here percent
of efficacy yeah you know
pretty bad you normally want more than
that right you want at least greater
than 50
well the reason i think that that's a
bad logic is as follows
if you were to run that experiment
for every person in the united states
and 10
of the population
benefited
that is about
134
000 people
is my mouth right there okay the math is
the math is way off so there's 330
million people in the u.s so 10 would be
33 million not 134 000. but that's also
pretty pretty irrelevant because
we're not dealing with most conditions
we're not dealing with a population base
that is the entire country so this is
very confused here juan i would do a
rethink on this okay there's a reason
that the double-blind placebo-controlled
trial is the gold standard and i would
rethink this all right on the bonus show
today we will talk about
the vote from twitter shareholders on
the elon musk twitter takeout takeover
we will talk about the founder of
patagonia donating the entire company to
fight climate change and yes we will
talk about the latest r kelly conviction
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
sign up at jointpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below